this week knocking Jared and I saw it
was the number-one grossing film of the
weekend Beauty and the Beast separately
not together not together together for
those who don't know you know this is
the this is obviously this is trailer we
can run it and kind of talk about this
as you see for those who missed it
I do love beating the beast gosh just
looking back on it shows me how much
they missed the mark okay I will say
this Beauty and the Beast is my favorite
Disney cartoon ever ever it's not even
close I think it's the best Disney
cartoon that they've made a beauty Anna
bees and I think a Toy Story series the
first thing I but watching his real-life
version the first thing I learned from
Beauty and the Beast is that in 1740
France slavery wasn't even a thing they
abolished slavery in 1794 I was sitting
there watching this and I know we're
gonna get flack for this but here's the
deal when you're complaining about
Scarlett Johansson appropriating a
Japanese character or Matt Damon not
really a Mongolian or white people
taking these black characters first off
this is a film that comes from an era
when slavery existed and they make up
like 30% of the main it make up 14% of
the population smart France and they
make up more of the main cast in it we
just have to suspend disbelief well yeah
yeah the black people could be royalty
and pattered what you just put sure I'm
sitting there watching this going we're
it's silly I'm talking about a film with
a with it with a with a flying with a
flying rug and a talking clock I
understand that it's silly but it's just
a silly to get mad about Scarlett
Johansson playing a Japanese cartoon
character and everything has to be
moonlight and everything has to be civil
rights and filling quotas and I was
watching this disco like this is the
silliest thing okay so that what was
what did you think about beating the
beast what did I think I thought well
graph excited just quickened on that
beast kind of sucked I think the the can
will do yeah sucked
I didn't hear I didn't think the candle
on that stuff sucked I just think
there's no way for them to really the
way they did it there was really no
facial expression from him at all I
think you get a choice to make that
looks like
be more realistic or give it the face
cuz I'm you see what the beast the face
just really fake and I think he was a
horrible cast at a Ewan McGregor I
thought it was just horrible miscast his
accent change like 16 times for the
candle yeah it was bad yeah it's bad
well I think you know it's just a film
that worked better in cartoon you know
for example when you watch the original
I'll tell you this no as a kid I got
really emotional when she's talking to
the Beast the final scene in the Beast
you know I love you the last rose petal
falls and the Beast lifts up but when
you see it and it's clear like a crappy
green screen sketch on the ladder with
Crowder where her hand is on the face
and I like the depth isn't consistent
quick cut to the point let's switch
quick that's right she hasn't shown up
and two and a half acts yeah exactly I
I feel like every scene that had so much
gravitas in the cartoon it has a cartoon
it's like they took like a like a really
crappy like like rehearsal of it and
like I'm a third take like yeah that's
good up run that yeah that's good let's
run that one just none of that had to
have we need him holding guests on over
the thing like that part of my way for a
Gaston I can't believe Gaston was just
this it just didn't work he wasn't an
intimidating character it was a douchey
enough he wasn't douchey nothing he
wasn't a very masculine looking
character there wasn't enough of a con
when even the Prince and Gaston when
they're next to Emma Watson who by the
way I just don't get we're gonna hire
eyebrows and pencil in her lip so it
looks like she has it I just don't get
the Emma Watson thing they there isn't
even a contrast Gaston and the prints
look the same plate is Emma Watson yeah
I'm sitting there's just like this is
just I just it didn't work it removed
you from it and a few key things like it
looked very much as though it were a
stage play when she goes up onto the
mountaintops singing than all these
flowers which could have been a
beautiful scene for example if you look
at me you're a heart well as green
screen yeah there's Mariana and then
green screen it's like this is should be
a soaring moment in this film if you're
going to take a cartoon which is kind of
not quite like a book but it allows
people to to sort of picture what it
really would be in reality if you're
going to actually create that in reality
it should be I candy it needs to be void
back you need to have a reason to make
it and with this they took it they took
someone who's less pretty than Belle and
someone who could not sing so they had
to auto tuner Emma Watson maybe she
who's obvious someone who can't
with a lot of auto-tuning you had as
Lefou Lefou Lefou Josh GAD was there he
wasn't bad but every time I see Josh GAD
it's one of those thing where I just go
like oh like it's a role that would have
been better you'll see with Jack Black
always among I could have been Jack
Black
[Music]
right there that's Jack Black I mean
he's a guy who's it like an operetta
Klee trained singer you know tasty John
but I'm just sitting there go this is
the role that was written for Jack Black
Beauty and the Beast short little fat
guy who has a musical number
yeah is there anyone who could do this I
don't know all I had said the gay thing
was definitely I think overblown from
the big a thing was overblown in fact I
he's creepy and annoying kinda gross and
that you're kind of just wincing waiting
for that moment that they hyped up in
the media but all that aside kiss there
was okay kiss all that sight it was
probably the most interesting part of
watching because it was the only
unpredictable part that wasn't copy
paste for the cartoon and then worse it
was pretty interesting was it was funny
but here's the deal the fact that there
are a couple scenes in there where they
they make it a gay thing they do at a
gay dynamic with Gaston and Lefou and
they do there's another thing with a
wardrobe and transgender wardrobe which
you shouldn't really matter less we're
talking about a Disney film but that
scene could have been in any movie 20 30
years ago you just never would have
thought transgendered well that's one
this one they do a little wink and a nod
I'm free be free be free and the guy
walks office yeah I really would rather
wear a dress and it takes things that at
some point you know we're just normal
for example you look back at white
Christmas they dressed up and then to
the sisters act it was totally wasn't no
one assumed that they wanted to go
through hormone replacement there you
know for example look through and
guessed on everyone just this was a
toady this was a Lackey this was a man
who was kind of a coward and who looked
up to Gaston and these relationships
whether it's really close friendships
male bonding now you see that with the
Avengers like oh are they gay
they really do feel the need to fit it
into everything and they wedge it into
every single male relationship for
example I look up to that man are you
secretly gay no I'm really close to this
man are you secretly gay no hey one time
I dressed up as a woman for a standard
for a stand-up sketch are you secretly
gay no they make a gay dynamic to
everything and I think that's why people
talked about the controversy
more because people are getting a little
bit tired of it being injected
everything I don't think they even
needed it cuz I do think it was
something to drive some publicity but
it's Beauty and the Beast like I think
it's going to carry the box office with
no problem because of its name
that's it you can suck and people will
still go and see it well and you had a
good point though about this so the only
Oh gay character in the film so that
very little has changed from the the the
animated version except for the fact
that they have some new songs which suck
the new songs are terrible the old songs
are auto-tuned and made to be lesser
versions of themselves the new song
sucks and the gay character that's the
new thing so the only change in the
storyline Jared noticed was with Lefou
with the flute the character arc is very
different in the cartoon he was a total
douchebag like just the nastiest looking
thing at the end of the cartoon he was
just like storm and the castle burning
people alive was a statist
it was say this he was nasty and ugly
and just like turning like this right
total monster that's all thing he was
conscious not original in the cartoon
but in this one he's gay so then what
happened so then it's like is it says it
they're like hey let's make this gay
character and we'll be awesome and we'll
introduce him and like he's going down
and they got to that seemed filming the
scene and it's like the darling oh my
gosh oh my gosh weak this makes holy SH
this makes him the villain yeah we can
[Applause]
so they reverse it and they make him all
of a sudden a good guy yeah I get it
just makes you think the kind of right
in the script is annotation or like hey
do we need a storyboard this can we just
shoot this in chronological order I
don't know what's happening this we need
to change it we can just say hey I'm
literally will they change it with one
word of dialogue I used to be with guest
on but now we're kind of in a weird
place right now and now he's a good guy
because everyone hates him but they
can't leave you hating the gay guy
no but only leave you hating the
straights is five foot four males yes in
Gaston I don't think the film was great
I don't think it was bad I do like
musicals I know where they're after all
this we're gonna get some comments but I
thought that the animation was bad I
thought it kind of took you out of the
film I think the cartoon was better it
was a lousy deal was as big of a deal as
people make it out to be but the fact
that they have to inject it into
everything all the time is just a little
bit annoying and I think that Walt
Disney is turning over in his
cryogenically frozen chamber
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they prefer to be
[Music]
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you didn't like this video you should
subscribe anyway because then you can
watch the next video and what you can do
is down vote it and leave a comment
that's really negative you know
particularly if it's something like I
don't know maybe anti somatic even
though I'm not Jewish or something about
my hair or something about my weird nose
just leave a really negative comments
that everyone else around can act like
they care